The Daily Beast slammed out Dean with
this headline Jason Aldean catches heat
for racist pro-gun lyrics a modern
lynching song the outlet claims that the
song is not just a statement of Aldean's
personal politics but a disturbing Call
to Arms quote unquote they accused the
singer of quote suggesting that he's
gearing up for a race war and by the way
they're evidence for that accusation
that he mentions a race war in the song
is uh they they quote this lyric from
the song got a gun that my granddad gave
me they say one day they're gonna round
up so The Daily Beast sees a race war in
that line somehow I don't see it but I
guess this is like the leftist version
of finding Jesus in a piece of toast I
don't know